let's say that today and we'll call
today day one day one is a Monday what I
want to figure out is what is day 300
going to be day 300 what day of the week
will day 300 be and I encourage you to
pause this video and think about that a
little bit so let's just write out the
days of the week you have Monday this in
a different color you have Monday
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday
Saturday and Sunday so if we had a lower
number here we could just fill out this
fill up fill this out Monday is day one
Tuesday's day two Wednesday day three
four five six seven I'll keep going day
eight well that's going to be a Monday
again nine ten I'm almost writing a
calendar out eleven twelve thirteen
fourteen fifteen sixteen so this is kind
of useful I could just write it out if I
wanted to figure out something you know
day 16 or day 20 I could just write that
out but this isn't that helpful if I
wanted to figure out day 300 or
especially wouldn't be helpful if I
wanted to figure out day 3000 so can I
come up with some mathematical way of
thinking about what day 300 is going to
be well when I as you see when I started
drawing this grid here
this grid has rows and in each row you
have seven days in it and that makes
sense there are seven days of the week
so is there a way that if someone just
gave you 16 without drawing this grid
that you would know that 16 is a Tuesday
well one way to think about it that
might jump out at you is you could
divide 16 by 7 that will tell you how
many of these rows will come before 16
that will tell you how many rows come
before 16 so 16 divided by 7 is 2 you
have 2 rows before 16 right over here
you could get 7 into 16 2 times and then
you have a remainder and then you have a
remainder what is the remainder when you
divide 16 by 7 16 divided by 7 well is
going to be 2
two times seven is fourteen you're going
to have a remainder of two so when we
divide we we've historically cared more
about this two we normally care more
about well how many times does it go
into it but now the remainder is
actually interesting the remainder is
really interesting here because the
remainder tells you the the first two
just tells you well seven goes into 16
two times that's how many rows you have
before getting to the sixteen but then
the remainder tells you well in that row
where is the 16 so the 16 is remainder 2
so 16 is not the first it's the second
entry in the third row and so it's going
to be a Tuesday Tuesday is the second
day I know what you're saying does that
always work well let's try it out with
some some other examples let's imagine
day 25 day 25 so let's just divide 25 by
7 so I'll do it right over I could do it
I make sure I have enough space so if I
have 7 goes into 25 it goes 3 times 3
times 7 is 21 you have a remainder of 4
so let's see so based on that so let me
rewrite this so 25 divided by 7 is equal
to 3 remainder 4 so it's equal to 3
remainder 4 so based on this if we were
to write out the grid we should have
three rows of seven before we get to the
25 and then 25 should sit into the in
the fourth column so if it's sitting in
the fourth column it should be a
Thursday so day 35 day 25 based on this
little math we just did should be a
Thursday let's see if that actually
works out so let's go to 17 18 19 20 21
22 23 24 and 25 it is indeed a Thursday
but it makes complete sense you could
get seven rows in it before the row that
gets to 25 and then in that row it's
going to be the fourth entry because you
have a remainder four one two three four
it's going to be a Thursday so now we're
ready to answer the question what is day
three
300 going to be so let's just divide 300
let's just divide 300 by 7 and see where
we get 7 goes into 30 4 times 4 times 4
times 7 is 28 subtract you get to bring
down a 0 7 goes into 20 2 times 2 times
7 is 14 and then we get our remainder
and now we care much more about the
remainder 20 20 minus 14 is 6 so our
remainder is 6 so if we think about what
day of the week it is in its row it's
going to be the 6th entry it's going to
be the 6th column there's going to be 42
rows above it but we care about which
entry it is in its row so day 300 is
going to be the 6th day of the week the
way we've written it out it is going to
be it is going to be a Saturday